uh so
uh i'm now very pleased to introduce uh
dan sepchef who is a professor at
carnegie valley university and who is
going to be speaking on local boss with
fine distance and the associated
gradient gloves
it has been uh really uh
an amazing uh two months for me at the
simons institute and uh
i'm quite happy to uh be here
uh
and uh i'll continue kind of on on on
these teams so maybe to give a little
bit uh
so you know somehow in
antonio stocks things got really
complicated and really technical on some
level but uh the underlying somehow uh
goal was actually
quite simple right can we have uh
somehow some formalism in which uh you
can write down equations let's say if
you're given two samples and you write
down your model right then we often do
that let's say with uh if you're
considering graph laplacian right you're
considering a random sample of your data
you are so you know you're looking at
spectral property of the draft laplacian
and you would like your answers to be
stable with respect to the sample that
you get and then there are reasons to
consider dynamical models also on the
grass and this no local interaction was
you know kind of an example
uh
that kind of we
could somewhat understand right but the
goal is again can we somehow
develop a stability for dynamical
equations if one could or basically even
just the ability to pose
the
models on graphs in a way that would be
consistent over
of the overlooking at different samples
of the measure that you're considering
and then considering the limits as n
goes to infinity you get more and more
data you would like to this to be
consistent with some equation that you
obtain in the limit and thus right we
looked at this framework which allows us
to consider both the discrete and the
continuum problems within one frameworks
and actually quite gen so the discrete
would be if mu was just an empirical
measure of the sample or at the
underlying space and continuing was if
mu was maybe
uh volume form on a manifold right and
okay that led us to somehow considered
these
so you know going from graphs to you
know on graphs right the transport is
always via jumps and that led us to
consider these non-local continuity
equations and the non-local vassar stand
metric and that is what i will continue
today uh almost all of what i'll talk
about is joint work with andrew wright
who
you guys have uh got to know over these
uh uh over this time and who would be
happy to answer all of the technical
questions about uh
the work uh
and uh right uh actually there is a good
overlap of some of my slides with what
antonio has uh talked about right that
was kind of the start of this and uh
uh
kind of some of the use of these models
to uh problems in machine learning and
what difference that they make you can
take a look at this uh
uh somehow recent work with uh katie and
nicholas so somehow
uh you could see why i'm so happy to be
here right so
and the background uh
for this i mean there is really this uh
wonderful paper by erbar in 2014 where
he actually introduced the non-local
vassar stand distance that i think is
kind of a little bit underappreciated
it's really an amazing paper and
in kind of the asymptotics the results
that uh we'll be considering somehow
nicholas was the first to uh
uh look at that and show that on random
geometric graphs uh
the wasserstein distance uh converges in
the chromosome sense to the standard
western uh
standard versus distance but in what we
did today you could see you could
actually uh see it as a more
quantitative uh other you know uh look
at the same question
okay so
what is the
somehow problem that we are considering
so
right there is this famous dynamical
formulation of the wastage and distance
by
uh benue brainia right so there are some
two elements right is what is the
geometry of the space that you're
considering so we're looking at the
space of measures and the paths in the
space are going to be
these uh
curves right described by the continuity
equation so the continuity equation
gives me curves uh in the space that i'm
considering and you know in this case uh
right there are some uh
uh irregularity assumptions but very
much is that the velocity is l2 with
respect to the current density and then
we have the action function where we
measure what is the action or
along that curve which then allows us to
define somehow the metric right and now
what you know what our goal is you know
kind of on an abstract level would be
can we build such framework you know if
we consider
no local uh distances so
sorry not non-local but no local
transport right okay so to introduce new
local transport i think it might be
easier kind of to do it in a little bit
of generality and introduce uh some
unknown local calculus right this is not
new right so somehow uh there is this
very popular paper by osher and gilbert
right so this was used in uh imaging or
you know in people who do peridynamics
and so on they would use very similar uh
non-local calculus right so given a
function we introduce a new non-local
gradient right there are no quotients
you just look at the differences of the
function at two points and we also
introduce a null local diversions and
okay here we diverge a little bit from
what people typically do
but i think that this is the right thing
to do so if you're given a kernel ada
right then you're uh
right
uh well actually we don't diverge in
yeah but anyways so
we diverge maybe in both points but uh
uh
but okay the divergence is defined
as uh the integral of this uh
measure j over the edges integrated
against my kernel era right so basically
what does this mean right so so now the
transport is not happening by a vector
field that is going to be moving mass
here and there but i have a direct link
between
location x and location y and i have
this preflux which you can in some ways
think of as to what is the force by
which i'm pushing whatever i'm pushing
on the on this
exclusive pipe from x to y
and uh eta in some sense is the width of
the pipe it's telling you what is the
capacity for you to transport from x to
y
and in you know basically if i look at
this product that should actually be
considered as a flux but okay we call j
uh the flux one can of course define it
in a okay in full generality when fluxes
are just measures via
the
uh adrian formulation that then
justifies also automatically uh certain
integration by parts
with this somehow uh so okay in this way
right so we define what does it mean to
be
transport along the grass right but uh
if i also have the notion of uh
mass so basically if i also know how
much stuff i have at any location in
this maybe either on a graph or in the
continuum right then i would like to
have kind of a genuine
somehow non-local form of the continuity
equation but in the continuity equation
right what we have is that uh
is that the
the relationship between the right okay
so careful
the relationship between the velocity
and flux is such that you take the
velocity and multiply it by density to
get the flux now velocity would make
sense on the edges right okay so this is
how fast are things moving from x to y
in some sense but the density doesn't
make sense on the edges right i know how
much mass i have the origin i know how
much mass i have at the target but you
know i don't have directly
a natural way to say what it is on the
edges so this was realized that there
was this actually three lines of work so
by mass by milk and by the group with
georgia tech airbar came later uh
who considered so what should be somehow
the graph analog of uh somehow
transportation and of vassars and metric
on a graph and they realized okay to
make sense of the continuity equation i
need to define the density along the
edges and we will do that by considering
an interpolation of what we have at the
beginning and at the end and as it as
you will see as it turns out this
interpolation actually has a very large
effect on
both the kind of the geometry of this
space and of the on the resulting
dynamics
but okay so you know what we certainly
want of the interpolation is that okay
it's homogeneous of degree one it's uh
non decreasing and it's uh oh sorry it's
increasing in with variables and it's
always greater or equal than zero so
with this uh
you know if i'm now able to write down
the continuity equation then we can
write down the analog of the action and
we can thus define or you know this is
like in antonio's talk so first i give
an intu relatively intuitive definition
that doesn't quite work out but then
later we'll fix this so
so the no local version vacation metric
right then is defined in this way right
so my paths well you know this is kind
of can be seen as a oh you know
everything is now non-local my paths are
solutions of the non-local equation
which are really this
continuum jump process where you're
instantaneously jumping
everywhere where
uh eta allows you right
and uh then you're measuring the action
to be this uh quadratic functional that
resembles the kinetic energy from before
right and okay so the interpolation
which i as i said will become important
right is
so
uh
some of the most considered ones for
such that when you interpolate between
let's say something positive let's say
one and zero you get zero so what are
the averages that have that perfect
let's say geometric average rate would
have that property or logarithmic
average which is the key in the working
is going to come later or kind of you
know any of these parallel type averages
then there is uh the arithmetic mean
right so
if you
look at uh
right so just literally average between
two locations right however this uh
creates the following problem let's say
at the location where i am uh there is i
have no mass but i look at the target uh
my target and there is some mass over
there
so then i take the arithmetic mean and
okay i now see okay there is some mass
to be transported and i feel the
potential and i started sending mass but
it didn't have anything so the
positivity would not be preserved okay
so that is not really kind of a problem
it's more of a technical uh annoyance
right is that now your tangent space so
basically i i actually like this place
quite a bit right but uh the the the
thing is that now what you're
considering is really not manifold
without boundary your tangent space is
not going to be the space of js is not
going to be a linear space but it's
going to be a certain subspace which is
basically a cone
you know infinite dimensional cone in
the space of uh
you know probability or sorry in the
space of measures j but that is somehow
entirely fine right i mean we are used
to looking at manifolds with boundary
and manifolds with corner we just need
to look at the interior tangent cone and
that is what also needs to be done in
this case
and okay then there is this upwind
interpolation which is what antonio
devoted most of the talk to right where
uh
we have this asymmetry this is kind of
inspired actually by the upwind schemes
right then numerically it works very
nicely right but geometrically it's sort
of a nightmare right as it turned out
but uh
uh so on one hand with this wonderful
right that this uh geometric framework
of uh
uh you know ambrosia jiggly sub array
right you know this in general geometric
viewpoint of the washington graduate
phones is so robust that even
with stood uh working with these
fincelerian
uh
non-symmetric uh forms right so
everything somehow is fine
uh but you know the stability issues and
so on become uh a nightmare so we don't
know somehow how to address them because
in particular geodesic convexity does
not imply stability
right
okay so
you know to to go you know to make this
connection right that you know mass and
others have made let me just very
briefly look at what happens somehow on
the graph so
we look at a graph uh
let's look at this kernel eta and let's
say that the edge weighs w i j is when i
evaluate in most of my talker the kernel
ada is going to be this radially
symmetric kernel although you know this
is again uh just technical convenience
then if i define you know given this uh
edge weights i define the weighted
degree as the sum of all of the edges
that emanate from that degree then we
have this unweighted graph laplacian and
if you have a graph of plus and you have
a graph heat equation okay
so
uh
what uh mask had noted is that the graph
heat equation is a gradient flow of the
entropy
with respect to the graph versus the
distance if and only if one takes uh
this logarithmic mean between r and s so
you can check that this is a
mean between two numbers right you know
you have to take you know if r is equal
to s you need to take the limit and show
that this is actually equal to r and i
note that uh you know if you take the
that one of them goes to zero you obtain
that the interpolation between something
positive and zero is equal to zero so
this is wonderful if it's very enjoyable
to do this exercise and check that this
is indeed the case
uh however right and also as antonio
noted if i look at the uh the
interpolation right and i look at a
wonderful smooth potential energy right
let's say u of x is maybe quadratic in
my space and i start with a delta mass
right that mass is never going to move
right so the uh
the support doesn't have the ability to
expand uh if the kind of the my force is
uh finite what is happening with the
logarithm if uh when you have zero
density the force really becomes
infinite and exactly balances and this
is how this was chosen exactly balances
the logarithmic singularity of the
interpolation so that's why the heat
equation here would move things but
again i could consider entropy and i
just increase the singularity a little
bit over here and then even the entropy
will not move mass and the support will
uh not grow so somehow this chain you
know something you know somewhat mundane
let's say in uh works of nicolas let's
say if you consider measures where the
density is bounded from below by
something positive right so that you
cannot really touch theta then you can
show that in that setting your
interpolation doesn't matter everything
is nice
the real problems begin if uh you have
something compactly supported and then
it's really difficult to
uh but certainly there is nothing that
universally works yeah i should note
that right if i look at the power of row
and yeah or actually sorry even better
if i add these two together then you
would expect that you will get a [ __ ]
blank equation and okay you may call
that the fork or plank equation but you
have two uh drawbacks it's not going to
be a linear equation because this
logarithm while it is being nicely
cancelled by the logarithm the entropy
will not be cancelled by this energy
over here and the other thing is that
the
limit as if you were to you know take
the temperature to zero you would not
recover the transport equation because
again this does not work as the
transport equation so if you want to see
what is our suggestion for a good [ __ ]
plank equation you can look at the work
that uh katie and
nicholas and i did but i'm not going to
somehow address that in this talk it's
just that you know it's kind of a little
bit frustrating and surprisingly
difficult but then there are you know
then there are you know positive
surprises like we know what erbar has uh
pointed out so namely
okay in general right if i look at the
non-local diffusion equation something
like this this can be seen as a gradient
flow of entropy
uh
whenever i take this logarithmic
interpolation so my kernel era right is
still going to be present there and so
this is not the continuum in the
previous slide we were on a graph now in
the continuum i think something like
this and if we choose uh
the kernel to be
uh this power law kernel which is not
integrable right but you know up to two
degrees uh
below that then we obtain the fraction
of the you know well uh you know study
then very interesting fractional heat
equation so fraction of heat equation is
also gradient flow of entropy and
precisely with respect to non-local
versus metric i should say
we are able to treat in this what is
coming we are able to treat potentials
which are locally like this one so the
singularity is not a problem but the
tails the fact that this doesn't have
second moments is a problem and i you
know kind of what we are able to treat
does behave in terms of geometry
different than what the geometry of this
would be so if you like you know while i
didn't say what our results are it is a
very nice open problem to try to extend
whatever we do to
really the fractional diffusion equation
okay so right there are you know these
issues that um you know if i want to so
this was the motivation but if i want to
do something rigorously right there are
these issues is that you know
uh rho may you know contain atoms right
and then those formulas uh do not make
uh sense my j is going to be uh a
measure and then i was uh squaring that
measure
and uh right there is an issue with
convexity and in the fincelerian case
right there is also the issue with
asymmetry
again in general right one can deal with
mu describing you know kind of the
geometry of the configuration space
where is mass allowed to live
in most of my talk the we are going to
be considering the big measure whereas
antonio considers somehow uh general
measures over there okay so we have the
no local continuity equation and this is
exactly the same slide
that uh antonio had so good uh right
it's you know again it's just that flux
formulation integrated uh
against the test function then we have
this horrendous form of the action
function but again this is just due to
to be able to deal with these
measurability issues
of you know having to divide a square a
delta mass and then divided by another
delta mass right so
uh
and then okay what this is basically
saying is that like in uh the standard
framework if you have a curve which you
would describe as something of having
finite action then you can actually
recover velocity and have that that
velocity
is going to be
a kind of uh square integrable in this
non-local sense and furthermore that uh
the
you know so here
i actually like to think only of the
asymmetric vector fields or asymmetric
fluxes because that kind of gives you
kind of this detailed balance whatever
is coming out of x has to be accounted
for when it's coming in y instead of
kind of double summing
and okay we have that a is convex and
thus basically
uh lowers them continuous and satisfies
uh
also satisfy this compactness thing so
we can you know conduct approximation
arguments
i will say that uh the assumption in a
way that i need to have that
why is that i cannot take power bigger
than two uh you know in s right is this
compactness assumption right that we
locally need to be able to integrate
against uh quadratic measures so this is
uh
you know uh
this is also this is about where antonio
kind of finished with discussing some of
this metric right so
right we have that okay
minimizes exist it is jointly narrow
lowest and continuous
for the
upwind interpolation i will use t as he
did and for the other ones i will use w
because then it is really somehow metric
and okay now comes somehow our results
so
one thing is
is that uh
maybe let's
uh
let's start with the with the second one
right so imagine you you're giving so
this is where you look at this actually
expel problem which is what is the
distance between i have a mass of the
delta mass and now i would like to expel
it from that location and spread it in
any way that i can somehow nearby so
basically i could look at the infimum of
the distances so in the second point in
femurum of the distances between the
delta mass at the origin and any other
probability measure which has no mass at
the origin right and note that right so
you know if i want to move a delta mass
if i want to move it just a little bit
right note that there is there is no
obvious cheap way to do this because my
transport is that i take all the mass
and i have to move all the mass you know
pour it from my delta the mass to
wherever i want to somehow pour it and
what what happens really is that in
these you know kind of for the kernels
that we
you know most
of the time would look at which means in
a nice integral kernel maybe something
that you know we normalize that it
integrates to one if you consider this
with respect to the arithmetic mean then
your distance there is a constant so
that this is bigger than a positive
constant so there is a positive distance
between a delta mass and any other major
which doesn't have you know it's
difficult to move mass this is one of
the reasons why the potential or it's
not the same but it's kind of one of the
reasons why the potential is not able to
uh
you know uh move the delta mass at all
and what is even worse and i was sad
about this
uh is that if we consider those
interpolations where
you when you interpolate between you
know one and zero and you get zero then
you're actually not able to move mass at
all from uh
you're not able to move delta mass with
an integrable kernel eta right so
basically then the distance is
actually going to be
well i don't know i call it infinity
there is no path of finite length right
that connects so the
it's like the in female of an empty set
is infinity right so
uh
right so this kind of tells you that
this is this is very undesirable for
kind of building a geometry and this is
why kind of i prefer this one but if
you're in this setting like uh where
airbar had the uh
no loc the sorry the fractional heat
right where the kernel is not integral
near the origin then actually you're
able to move mass cheaply right in
particular we can construct paths that
have this scaling of the length between
so now i'm
okay since i can move it now then i can
measure things so if i look at the delta
mass supported in a bowl right then i we
have an upper estimate for what is the
distance between the delta mass by
constructing basically an explicit you
know
mass where we basically have some dyadic
sequence of uh annuli where we transport
it and you know
show that we can create a path somehow
of this length
so it is really
so what are the consequences of this one
is
yeah
is the constant c here in the second
point depending on eta
uh yeah yeah it's depending on it right
right yeah
okay right like if i scale properly try
to recover the continuous setting this
constant will actually go to zero that
is right yes yes uh right that is
a very quick observation yes
i was scared by the results
that happens to me too right
sometimes with a good reason but uh uh
uh
right
what is uh
what the first point really then kind of
suggests and what we are able to prove
is that if the kernel is not integrable
then the topology that you get is what
you expect from a vast extent distance
namely weak inverse variable measures we
don't have a good understanding what
happens at infinity right in terms of
moments and so on so let's say we
restrict to uh you know compactly
supported measures and then it maturizes
the same topology as vasterstein on the
other hand if i if you look at uh you
know this arithmetic case where you had
a reasonable metric right then we have
you know a lower bound which is uh in
terms of the total variation metric and
an upper bound which is you know in
terms again in terms of the
total variation plus you know this is
the
vasa stand metric with linear cost right
uh so munch distance right in it okay
this is the radius of the support so
there's some interpolation right the way
that we uh prove this but what the
second point says that in this case the
topology metric is stronger than
vasterstein it's precisely the strong
topology in the space of measures so the
one metrized by the total variation
right so we were you know we did not
expect it and okay you know i think uh
it's useful to somehow understand it
then in terms of what one can expect in
terms of convergence and so on
right and okay now in terms of uh
quantitative results so now let's
rescale the kernel and we rescale the
kernel rate in the way that you would uh
rescale a mollifier right so you know it
doesn't necessarily
uh
uh
may not be the kind of the first thing
to think of when you're doing those uh
non-integrable kernels but okay we we
stated everything in terms of this
rescaling then we basically have both
upper and lower error bounds on the
non-local vast extent metric in terms of
the true vascular metrics so you can see
we really need the second moments and
so the scripts double epsilon is the
non-local vascular steroid metric dw is
the standardization metric you know that
they're not kind of exactly of the same
flavor but uh i mean there is a you know
there is a square and here is square
root of epsilon here it's for the linear
distance right so do the techniques on
the proof
basically if you know if these are uh
right
uh
basically if one of these uh measures is
uh if you're just looking at the
distance to a fixed measure then it's
like fourth root of epsilon but if
you're looking at the error between
measures which are the substantial
distance then it's like square root of
epsilon and then
in that sense is
like the what we have on the other end
so very very briefly about uh
uh
what we do in the proof so we construct
the competitors sorry so we look at the
standard version and then we construct a
computer there and okay we we have two
kind of observations there so one which
i
uh really am happy with because it gives
us kind of a
uh some concrete object that we can work
with to understand is no local transport
so imagine you have the local transport
equation then you convolve it with any
kernel you still have a solution to
local transport but what is miraculous
is that if you build this kernel
miraculous i don't know uh nice
uh
yeah i mean not miraculous but uh
if you
build this special kernel okay
then your convolved uh solution to the
convol solution to the original
local
transport continuity equation becomes an
exact solution to the non-local
transport equation with this uh flux
defined like over there right
okay so we can build exact solution to
the non-local transport equation which
then you know you have really concrete
objects to work with the other
difficulty is that when i'm transporting
at a distance right
uh i need to be the problem is if you're
transporting let's say in an empty space
right then your interpolation right is
uh between the densities would
quantitatively be very different than
the density at one point which is what
the vastus and gdc could measure
so okay then there is one layer another
layer of appreciation which is
when you convolve with the laplacian
laplacian kernel has this beautiful i
mean a very useful property that if you
convolve with a laplacian kernel then
you can uh obtain a control on the
relative left sheets norm so basically
you can control the difference you know
let's say an estimate like this allows
you to control mu delta of y minus mu
delta x divided by mu delta y which then
allows you to control right kind of what
is the error when i'm replacing my
density with the interpolation okay that
was on one side on the other side we use
the dual problem because that allows you
then to build a competitor and we use
the hamilton jacobi formulation of the
dual problem we uh this was actually
wilfred we are thankful to wilfred
for their work because they introduced
they studied the on the graphs the dual
problem in terms of hamilton jacobi on
graphs and formulated what the kind of
dual problem would be we just extended
it here to measures and this was also
you know something like this was also
considered in a paper another paper by
uh jan moss i think airbar and weird
and okay then there are some technical
issues but okay with with all of that
you use the
uh vaserstein geodesic you modified you
control the error and that is what led
to those estimates and and this is
exactly where i wanted to stop sorry for
going a bit over time
[Applause]
that's a very brief question so the the
fact that you get a quasimetric
um with the upwind interpolation that
you mentioned
that has to do with the graph structure
right
so do they exist choices of each other
so that that actually is symmetric
well it's due to the interpolation that
we
do right so i don't see
right i wouldn't see how to make it uh
symmetric right
uh
i mean i need to think but uh let's say
the if there is ada that uh one could
try right then it would be try eta to be
constant right so let's say and see i
think we never really wrote it down
right but i i think that when you take
ada to be constant you get something
very similar to like the birth depth
dynamics into the
uh hellinger cutthroat uh not
sorry hellinger uh distance
that that is something that one you know
would be interesting to look at right
yeah i also have a quick question about
this admin interpolation so i'm more
familiar with is used in numerical
discretization and they designed for
hyperbolic conservation law and the
independent volume method and the final
volume accidents
basically solve a weak solution to the
continuity equation rather than scores
the setup have advanced scheme is
already taking the
account into i'm going to find the
distribution of solution raw rather than
solution
so um so that's why i see this
continuous formulation has this absolute
scheme
um so i try to try to find the
connection i wonder if there's actually
a more general
continuous
uh version of it while upbeam scheme is
one proper way to discretize it
right so yeah i also agree right that
also this is kind of the setting of weak
solutions also and uh
yeah i don't know if there is something
better right you know it would be uh
you know really good to know
what about the judges
we
yeah so right so
kind of the it would be nice to discuss
right so let's say if you just have on a
on a line a two point space then one can
write down some cell similar formulation
it might be possible maybe to solve that
integral equation right one thing that i
could remark on and i think this is uh
actually uh you know kind of uh useful
so
imagine so right so if i look at uh
right if i look at the energy e of rho
to be at n
the integral of u uh d rho right and i
take u to be convex this is not going to
be basically convex it may be
semiconductors i'm convinced that it's
semiconductors and one can obtain
quantitative estimates
or maybe right the reason why it's not
semiconductors is actually easy to see
so imagine that they take
in 2d and i take u of x to be just
absolute value of x2
and imagine that my initial measure is
uh in you know here sorry delta mass at
uh
the origin right at 0 0 and here delta
mass at uh one zero right
so what we can show i mean this is you
know really easy right is that easy
cannot stay on the line it has to spread
right so initially my energy is zero
finally minor is zero but in between it
has to spread vertically right
and uh come back i think what would be
really interesting if one could show
how much do gdc spread right if one can
obtain quantitative estimates and let's
say those constructions with the no you
know local to non-local continuity
equation they give you kind of some idea
as to how this should uh somehow happen
so i feel that this is kind of within
the realm of achievability that you can
show how much your gdc spreads and then
have a control on the semi-convexity
integrable versus non-detectable kernel
really something which caused problems
and applications because i can imagine
that if you have a discrete finite graph
then it's hard to distinguish how the
kernel actually behaves close to the
diagonal because you will never get in
these regimes
right so
uh
i mean again great that that kind of
would then limit you know the scalings
which between n and epsilon that uh
under which you would expect that your
drive dynamics would do one thing versus
another
i actually have a question so
what extent does this
this better understanding of the
function should you know color your
perspective on the best way to interpret
i mean it sounds like um
yeah it sounds like maybe you know you
can give perhaps even more potential for
this arithmetic need but just coping
with the fact that you have to work on
that
i don't know do you do you think that
this this sheds light on
um
you know better choices
right so uh maybe
i can answer another question that may
make you kind of uh answer what you're
kind of uh
you know he's in the background right so
somehow yeah i don't know how to choose
a good uh interpolation but uh i'll just
say
one of the interests why we're
interested in this continuous setting
because when you're on a graph right due
to the local structure of the graph a
lot of the convexity is lost right so
the heat equation is not kind of you
know the potential is not convex because
of the local structure of the graph but
what the airborne has shown that the
entropy is convex uh no one has a
uniform estimate but it he knows that
it's con
easily convex so it's possible to you
know in this continuum homogeneous space
which is translational variant is
possible to kind of have somehow nicer
estimates and then the question is what
is needed somehow to go from the graph
uh to here i feel that again all the
properties of the you know everything
that happens with the functional if it
happens on the length scale which is
shorter than the graph then shorter than
the length scale of the graph then kind
of
we could have somehow bad outcome so my
kind of suggestion would be can we in
fact actually modify functionals and
gradient flows in such a way
that they are not tripped by the local
structure of the graphene that allows us
a connection to these
non-local gradient flows in the
continuum again here this is just a hint
of an idea it's not you know nothing
concrete
okay well it's not a mistake
uh